if I could pay 20K
and I get these saggy [__] cheeks
looking like a Grandma's tit yeah lift
it up get it high and tight give me some
new ears
luscious lips baby what do you do about
the eyes though the really small eyes
I didn't know I had small eyes
[Music]
you're gonna like this because I you
kind of just like stuff like this
um do you know about idiopathic condylar
resorption yeah that's when you just
take the bad energy from the mental
space and you redistribute it throughout
the rest of the body to more uh what is
that because I I think I need help
whatever Nick is talking about being
Nick massage me what especially focus on
this air area right here there's a lot
of negative energy right here I need you
to distribute for me yeah it starts it
starts in the skull and then you work
your way down to the pelvic region can
we get it in person demonstration it
then you release it Mark can you
demonstrate on Nick what that is no I'll
demonstrate it on you I don't want you
to demonstrate enough
hey man
show Nick what it is no dude no [__]
anyway it's so strong I don't [__]
away you're not gonna take all the bags
over here yeah
[Laughter]
my penis
I let my guard down yeah you did
all the way down to Chinatown so is that
is the idea behind that you Channel all
the negative energy in your scrotum and
then you you jack them off so hard that
you shoot it out you release it yeah
yeah yeah that's one way to do it and
that's probably the most popular way to
do it can I can I say something really
interesting yeah Nick is so like
squirmish about this I felt like if I
had his dick in my hand and I went like
this
he would feel more Awkward than I would
oh
my dick get to my dick why does it need
to be observed I can't wait to hear the
actual definition
do you agree
no yeah if you put your lips on my penis
you're like you put it I'm like but it's
in my mouth but are you more Awkward
than him in a situation like that it's
really awkward for me he's the one with
it his Mountain on it hey dude you're
you touching anywhere near my penis is
not okay dude
[Laughter]
so
idiopathicondylar absorption
is when your um your jaw bone just
starts to break down and it just
disappears oh what yeah
it's just the condition that it's a
super rare condition and um is it like a
like osteoporosis where it's like it's
just like the bonus I think it just
breaks down in like it'll become soft
and then just kind of dissipate or
something dude that'd be [__] so what
happens is that uh your lower jaw
basically you know your TMG I don't know
if I don't know what that is but
apparently your TMG disappears and now
your lower jaw is no longer connected to
your skull I know what they should do
Wrigley's bubble gum
chew it man you're fast with those
diagnosis Solutions Yeah the more you
chew the more you get a [__] Jank ass
jaw that's a good catchphrase the more
you choose the more you get a [__]
drink
if you don't use it you lose it though
you know what I mean so you got to use
your or that we could say that you got
to use your job so uh the crazy thing is
this girl her name's Izzy she's 22 and
she has this condition tell her to stop
just drinking Jamba Juice all day long
she gotta chew her Foods
Jamba Juice is delicious right can you
imagine the doctor walks back with a
chart uh so you gotta stop drinking
[__] Jamba Juice
you gotta chew your food you gotta stop
eating smoothies
how's one in her yeah
what about smoothie bowls no how about
uh Juice It Up
at least like switch to Boba or
something that got a little chew
yeah eat steaks that are well done yeah
okay build up the jaw so here's what she
looks like she's um the sad thing is she
like talks about things that people have
said to make fun of her and she's been
told she looks like a a person that got
blown up in a war
whoa it's like so mean but yeah you see
her like her her cheeks go out and then
her so she had a jaw and it just slowly
as she got older it's just like going
wow you know what though it actually
looks a lot better than I had thought in
my head Well yeah if someone says hey
this girl you're gonna meet looks like
she was blown up in a war she don't like
she was blown up no she doesn't look
like that oh yeah that person was an ass
no they're just not funny she looks more
like a goldfish or like more like a no
no no a puffer fish a puffer fish that's
a cute one that's a cute one Ryan you
got any other ones but like
if you're gonna roast someone you gotta
do an accurate roast like you a guy that
looks blown up award that looks
that looks different yeah that's kind of
ours so what she did is she got a
prosthetic jaw piece installed into her
into her head from the inside uh yeah
and then they what they do is they take
belly fat and they pat it oh okay so is
that a is that a new jaw or that's the
previous jaw the one you just saw was
the no job no job no job that's what the
of something absorption right the idea
whatever absorption yeah so here's what
she looks like now after this
wow why is she wearing that shirt
geez dad I I want to see this picture
but with the with the no jaw sorry she's
confident hey sweetheart put a shirt on
huh what are we doing oh yeah she said
because the other one is just the
profile you know how long that procedure
is Gonna Last for her so like forever
I think it's I think it might be
technology because it's a it's uh yeah
because she's 22 because what if her
head girl's bigger and then she has to
get a new jaw because the Jaws like her
21 year old small jaw don't they say
your head doesn't stop growing well it
does it doesn't your nose your cartilage
your cartilage keeps growing your nose
and your ears yeah that's what I meant
to say Ryan back me up dude yeah sorry
pull up an article but yeah it's an
expensive surgery dude it costs it says
it cost uh 168k just for the surgeon and
200k for the surgery she got a 300 000
jaw oh my God John looks good though
um insurance
did the insurance cover it because
usually a lot of Cosmetics insurance is
uncovered I think because is it plastic
surgery so the reason why it's not
considered cosmetic is because when that
happens to your jaw you have a really
hard time breathing sleeping eating she
couldn't uh bite down on it she's never
had a caramel apple
like she can't she can't like put Force
like this yeah yeah see and I told her
to start chewing gum before early yeah
why didn't you listen to you she should
have had caramel apples earlier so now
it's functional and cosmetic yes exactly
yeah see I would take it a step further
and I would have got a bionic super
titanium jaw oh yeah so then like if if
I wanted to chew on something I could
chew on like a [__] two by four yeah
I could just break it through like Jaws
from gold knife if you had like a magnet
it would just like yeah you might set
off some TSA alarms you know like this
would you get this kind of jaw
You're Gonna Go to the mark a little bit
you could go full floor I would have
been sick if you're gonna spend 300
that's 300K job baby so the insurance
covered everything
I I don't know if they covered
everything but she did go through
insurance for it I don't know how much
they I'm sure they fought tooth and nail
to not cover everything yeah see this is
when I believe in plastic surgery
because people be like oh you should
just it's natural just God gave you that
you should be beautiful but then I'm
like but sometimes people are not like
given the gifts of beauty
she got [__] up so let her [__] fix
the [__] with technology yeah yeah why
not right bro if I was born with a with
a with a pair of flared ass noses that
went like that are bigger than my eyes
and I look like a gorilla and [__]
because it's like it's like this big and
then my ears are super small like
they're like and you couldn't hear super
super smart
I got really really small and then my my
lips are like non-existent oh and that
yeah you have a tiny mouth tiny ears I
look like a gray alien and [__] they
look like this I know a girl can someone
really looks like that that's offensive
he did no but that's giving me an
example yeah he did and then what if I
had no cheekbones it's just too droopy
saggy [__] cheeks like boobs it's
like old man boobs yeah
and then and then someone's like you
know what you're beautiful just the way
you are and I'm like [__] you because
you will not have sex with me yeah I am
not beautiful you're not throw me none
you liar and then everyone's like oh you
should accept the way that you are
because God created you that way and I'm
like [__] if I could pay 20K
and I get these saggy [__] cheeks
looking like a Grandma's tit yeah lift
it up get it high and tight give me some
new ears
luscious lips baby just a little filler
yeah and all of a sudden like what do
you do about the eyes though the really
small eyes
I didn't know I had small eyes
no your nose did you say you had small
no I had a big [__] nose
what do you do about the nostrils what
do you do about it nose job a 1990s no
job like Michael Jackson style beautiful
leopard I mean uh
Peter panels would you go sharp nose huh
would you go long pointy sharp whatever
the style is of the day the style right
now
whatever
whatever what's hot right now
remember in the 90s all the girls were
doing nose jobs they they wanted a more
tiny [__] fairy nose yeah is that
what they wanted that day they wanted
small like uh because nose jobs was a
thing for a while I'm sure that it is it
still is I think well now is it like
getting that nice strong bridge is that
like you know the Asian knows that
everyone like so like Asians want the
bridge right yeah but then when you get
the bad side of the Asian nose you get
the big like Pig style yeah yeah this
yeah yeah style I'm looking at
everyone's nostrils
no Bridge Pig style I don't know how
often I've seen Pig style that's because
it's rare
that's why it's rare and ugly it's not
it's
it line that says [__] you kiss
you
you're a liar like that's not the save
the cat moment right there if you think
I'm so hot why don't you sleep with me
is that a good script is this a good
script yeah
[Music]